differentiation right or rather a
derivative okay if you have a function
like y equals x squared or something
like that
okay the derivative we would usually
write that as dy/dx yes this is all just
old stuff right now that's just a
shorthand way of actually writing
gradient because that's what derivative
gives you it gives you the gradient
function okay so rise if you remember
back to when we were doing first
principles okay
that D is like the Delta you know it's
science it means change yeah
so change in Y that's what we really
need buy rise like how far is something
going up and changing X is well you
might run how far is it going
horizontally okay so if that's what the
derivative is when you're looking at the
functions and graphs and all that kind
of thing there really anytime you
compare two things that are changing
okay it doesn't have to be something
going up and down something going
horizontally give me anything right
anytime you compare two things that are
changing you've got a derivative okay so
as an example let's have a look at the
first question let's do a bit of a a bit
of decoding using this what you'll find
is a lot of a lot of just trying to wrap
your mind around these questions is just
interpreting my mates waters pouring it
to a container so that the volume flow
rate R equals DV of DT okay stop stop I
know the center to the finish but let's
just try and work this out okay there's
a flow rate and they're calling it ah
okay
but that are another way of sayin I flew
right is dv/dt now what does this mean
okay well if DUI or D X means how is y
changing as X changes okay do you guess
this bit yeah change in volume how much
that's getting bigger or smaller as time
progresses okay change in volume of each
meter that's a really important concept
to get by though so like I suggest you
write that this is change involving you
over change in time okay so we're try to
compare these two okay and when you
compare two things what you're getting
is a rate right it's like this per this
mils per hour or cubic centimeters per
second oh whatever it is okay it varies
with the time according to the relation
R equals K T squared so now they're
telling us that this RP right they give
you several days from the same thing
really
ah which is the same as DV DT that is K
sorry that's okay K T squared where K is
positive
okay so now this this looks good
I've got a rate of change right and it's
it's a new time and the actual rate is
in terms of time right I can calculate
the volume of water which is pointing to
the container in the first five seconds
give it that K is equal to all right
know that they commuters value so
they're saying okay is equal to and then
they put it in X form that's fine if you
want to put it in X well I find that
somewhat hard to read so I would write
it with division instead okay so you've
got a right here and the units are cubic
centimeters and seconds okay now we'll
have a thing laid out what we do I'm
going to change for Billy as to why
that's seconds square per second per
second but what we're really interested
in is the closetit the three is kind of
the important part of it so I could now
write this levy or detain you that's
three sweat okay right let's revisit my
question is to calculate the volume of
water which is pointed to the container
in the first five seconds okay right now
if I want to do something with volume I
can know a lot of things about volume
based on this race because just like if
you know what the derivative is you age
a different [ __ ] and go back to the
primitive and you'll get a function for
y right we're going to do the same thing
here it's just kind of different letters
yeah
so if I ain't I'd appreciate think about
okay what what function did this come
from before
what's the premium it's a messy one
yep okay so you've got a have you closed
that there you know what does that
correspond to I wonder if you remember
when I was talking about this is for
people who hear yesterday talking about
evaluating cluster integration right
constant of whatever okay what is it
referred to sometimes it's just a number
the cave is just some habitation but in
this case this C refers to the different
yeah because you think about this right
initial conditions that's where times 0
so that's we define our starting point
okay so at time is 0 what volume will be
there what is that the volume is there
will be 0 plus C all right now I don't
know they don't tell me anything about
how much it starts with it was like 50
this or 50,000 or well okay but it
doesn't matter can anyone tell me why
well it doesn't matter how much it's
always good right so I'm just interested
in not the actual total mouth but just
how much has it changed in that boys in
five seconds first five seconds
all right so how would you go about
actually sitting on working on this
answer maybe something you can see it
already okay if I want to compare the
first five seconds right I'm gonna say
well what's it going to be at the
beginning and we just said this right
we're T equals zero the volume of water
will be and I'm just gonna write this
out law here so you can see what I'm
doing then we zero cubed plus C right so
there's going to be see what you just
made mills juices coming q2 right okay
so that's how many cubic centimeters of
water in there I don't know what it is
don't need to know right if I don't know
what happened to the first five seconds
now I'll compare with what happens after
that time has elapsed right
so when I go straight to that value the
volume is now going to be this
now you can see why I don't need to know
what the cluster is okay because all I'm
interested in is this actual tape okay
so therefore in the first five seconds
125 cubic centimeters of water has
poured it including
Televisa I think it's I think it's plain
enough for them it's a nice simple okay
Sookie see how I set it out does that
make sense in this case we didn't need
to work out that because it was because
of the particular kind of question that
at once